on va se poser une question cette
semaine
est ce que le ministère des forêts du
québec devrait pas plutôt s'appeler le
ministère l'industrie forestière
on ignore pour l'industrie qui dit fais
ce danois ça change ça les lobbys
industriels soient extrêmement tous à
une gestion déficiente qui ne protège ni
la forêt ni l'argent des québécois c'est
celui qui coupe la route qui décide
combien vaut payer au gouvernement
c'est comme tu y es tu donnais un cheikh
arabe les monos prescrire des lanceurs
d'alert qui connaissent de l'intérieur
le ministère de la forêt ont accepté de
nous parler
est ce qu'ils vont révéler va donner de
nouveaux arguments à ceux qui demandent
une enquête publique sur la gestion de
la forêt y a pas de contre partie civile
pour contester leur décision alors c'est
comme un étendard je ne dors ici marie
mot déni
bienvenue à enquête
m
[Musique]
les forêts québécoises qui recouvre la
moitié de la province sont une de nos
plus belles cartes postales nous sommes
propriétaires collectivement de cette
richesse
92% des forêts son public la gestion des
coupes forestières suscite donc de vives
tensions
quand on fera des extrémistes qui
permettent de dire ben nous le soit a
forcé sa pas de bon sens la forêt est en
train de détruire la forêt au québec on
est loin de l'eau d'un côté l'industrie
et les municipalités forestière des
forts d'une économie qui roule
littéralement sur le bois et qui
génèrent 60 mille emplois on dirait
qu'on n'a plus pour refuser déco
faurecia
de l'autre il y a de plus en plus de
citoyens et d'écologistes qui veulent
sauver des forêts pour leur donner
d'autres vocations
il vous faudra que la société se
réveille puis qu'il fasse comprendre où
on en a marre que la forêt ce cépage et
s'il courra bois de compagnie cb maître
le chien celui qui est pris entre
l'arbre et les corses c'est le ministère
des forêts mais plusieurs estiment qu'il
est de mèche avec industrie et que sa
priorité c'est l'argent qui pose dans
les arbres
[Musique]
voici en haute-mauricie un territoire
sauvage aussi grand que la belgique ici
l'industrie forestière est au coeur de
l'économie depuis des générations
en sillonnant les chemins forestiers on
découvre des centaines de tronçons à
gauche et à droite qui mène à d'anciens
chantier de bûcheron ou un des secteurs
en opération ont été revus complètement
au début du développement de la région
aussi iliad a poli et l'autre qu'on aura
vu leurs manies ce qu'il fait à peu près
7000 âmes eyed peas a fini l'oeil avec
romain puisque le polar comme selon là
on rencontre la peau deux pick up
chantal et jean marc se sont installés
au milieu de cette forêt près du
réservoir gouin
il ya plus de 15 ans depuis le paysage a
bien changé quand les compagnies
faurecia l'on commence à m'en fous mais
on commencera à produire du chemin tracé
développés que les années là avec les
découpes de broc qui ont fermé fallait
croiser les principales comme ici à sa
mère après son bac fois les coupes de
bois ont fait du maître pénétration
j'ai eu beaucoup de m quand je m'en veux
me tourner le fameux col mao ils ont
laissé derrière leur joliette natale
pour mettre sur pied une petite
quinzaine à 300 km de la tuque la patate
bon je suis la première mais était un
avantage du parking puis à 1 ou
d'accords dessus il y avait acheté de
plus et que tout le vélo on faisait de
la peine leur casse croûte est devenu
l'auberge la patate dugoin qui se trouve
à la croisée des chemins forestiers qui
mène en abitibi en mauricie dans le nord
du québec et au lac saint jean
[Musique]
cent quatorze mois jeudi matin des chars
combien
ces gens là je joue comme ils sont loin
de tous les services
chantal et jean marc sont devenus les
anges gardiens du secteur elles soignent
les blessés dans les cas d'urgence et il
assiste les gens qui ont des pépins sur
la route
[Musique]
ce sont eux d'ailleurs qui nous ont aidé
à retrouver notre chemin quand on s'est
perdus pendant des heures dans ce
labyrinthe sans fin sans signal gps ni
réseau cellulaire
on a presque manqué d'essence on est
comme une famille
autre en milieu boss ce couple a vu
pousser les kilomètres de chemins
forestiers
il y en a maintenant plus de 30 mais la
haute mauricie le problème c'est que
cette prolifération et la pointe de
l'iceberg d'une déforestation à plus
grande échelle que des conséquences
environnementales et économiques
c'est très important on dit au québec et
poète déforestation le territoire est
stable mais ce qu'on a qu'il peut
s'apparenter à la gravité ou à ce type
de défi là c'est le morcellement du
territoire et tenez vous bien le québec
compte désormais quatre cent soixante
huit mille kilomètres de chemins
forestiers
oui 468 1000 km qui sont là pour rester
c'est l'équivalent de 10 fois et demi le
tour de la planète terre des chiffres
qui préoccupent l'ex forestier en chef
du québec gérard sarrailh finalement les
chemins forestiers c'est l'industrie qui
avait ouvert pour aller à les récolter
et là dans bien des cas on est rendu au
bout le tapis a été déroulé on est
d'arriver au bout il faut revenir moan
était c'est un peu comme l'arbre qui
cache la forêt parce que l'impact des
chemins est souvent plus important que
les coupes forestières et pour
l'industrie ça représente une perte ces
milliers de kilomètres ne pourront être
récoltées dans le futur
si on imagine quand on construit une
heureuse qu'il faut le compact et on
reprend le camion qui chargé de bois qui
je sais pas combien de tonnes
s'effondrer à la suite yari qui pousse
de dan
ce déboisement casier réversible et le
résultat du système vont rester en place
[Musique]
pendant que lèvres
g
après des décennies d'exploitation
forestière le documentaire de richard
desjardins l'erreur boréale a provoqué
une onde de choc au tournant du
millénaire en montrant la déforestation
du québec et les coupes à blanc au grand
écran je me suis aperçu que entre y
avait une grande distorsion entre le
discours officiel forestiers des
compagnies du gouvernement est ce que je
voyais - un petit avion à deux tours
mieux pinet il ya une distorsion qui me
paraît absolument incroyable s'en est
suivie la commission coulombe puis une
refonte complète du régime forestier
pour aménager les forêts durablement le
gouvernement a pris le contrôle de toute
la planification forestière qui
relevaient auparavant de l'industrie et
il a réduit la taille des chantiers de
manière draconienne pour satisfaire
l'opinion publique
je suis toujours de penser que nos
bonnes périodes comme nous mène à
l'enfer
en fait en misant sur des petites coupes
en mosaïque et des coupes partiel une
ombre de route forestière a explosé et
les abatteuses doivent y retourner plus
souvent sur le territoire de la tuque le
nombre de chantiers a été multiplié par
25 pour éviter des normes coupable en
675 secteur de coupe plutôt qu en avoir
trop bas tu passes ton temps à te
déplacer pour récolter ou avoir des
petites assiettes de code donc c'est pas
profitable berne en témoigne
dérangeant mais on a besoin d'une région
routier qui est beaucoup plus développée
pour accéder à toutes ces endroits
pourtant il y a quinze ans le professeur
daniel michaud avait sonné l'alarmé sur
les impacts du développement anarchique
de la voirie forestière au québec il se
construisait alors entre quatre et cinq
mille kilomètres par année
depuis la situation n'a fait qu'empirer
la récolte forestière est beaucoup plus
morcelé dans le territoire forestier au
québec
donc ça nous amène est obligé de faire
plus de chemins forestiers pour le
transport et l'accès à la ressource
c'est loin de faire le bonheur de la
coopérative forestière du haut saint
maurice qui peinent à être rentables ces
entrepreneurs reçoivent le même cri par
mètre cube de bois coupé qu'il y avait
un temps là la consommation de plus
grande en diesel de toutes les machines
aussi toutes les équipements lourds
ça nous en train de plus en plus pour
être capable de récolter le même nombre
de métiers globaux au québec
une grande partie de la construction de
ce réseau routier est payé par les
contribuables en 2019 2020 le
gouvernement a versé près de 5 millions
de dollars en subventions aux compagnies
forestières pour ces chemins aussi
destiné aux pourvoyeurs aux chasseurs
aux autochtones et aux touristes en
foresterie on dit maintenant fait plus
des chemins forestiers ont fait des
chemins multiressources la légende du
barça veut dire que c'est que tout le
monde peut l'utiliser c'est vrai mais la
réalité tous ces chemins leur sont
faites pour l'industrie en premier
écologiste de la première heure en
abitibi henri jacob crois que les
compagnies devraient assumer seule les
coûts de ces chemins selon lui ce sont
des subventions déguisées
ils sont faites dans le but d'exploiter
la forêt et pourquoi qu'on change le
vocabulaire lors dans le sco is it c'est
assez simple c'est qu'on sait que aux
états unis dans les échanges
commerciales si on aussi le gouvernement
dirigé subventionner les chemins des
forestières il ya là des
des compensations à donner outre les
enjeux politiques et économiques
il reste que la construction effrénée
des chemins un impact sur la
biodiversité et les espèces en péril un
territoire quadrillé facile et de
l'accès aux prédateurs comme pour le
caribou lé les chemins c'est la voie
d'accès pour les loups les ours c'est
très important de maintenir ces
territoires sauvages combien d'autres
espèces escobar chassés de leur
territoire à cause de sentences gardien
contrairement à l'ontario et aux états
unis qui ont encadré la construction de
chemins forestiers
le québec tarde à le faire en 2004 le
rapport coulon a conclu et qu'il restait
environ 15% de forêt boréale vierge dans
la province
justement parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'accès terrestre est impossible de
savoir ce qui en est aujourd'hui le
ministère des forêts répond qu'il ne
comptabilise pas ces superficies parce
que la commission coulom la pause
établit les critères d'une forêt vierge
[Musique]
après la pause une lanceuse d'alert nous
dit comment ça se passe vraiment à
l'intérieur du ministère des forêts on
tourne les coins ronds sega rocher
il ya tellement d'improvisation parmi
les critiques de la gestion forestière
au québec il ya des militants qui
pensent que le ministère est à la seule
industrie forestière mais à l'intérieur
même du ministère il ya des gens qui
savent comment ça se passe et on a
convaincu une fonctionnaire de témoigner
la région de la mauricie a été témoin de
l'âge d'or de l'industrie forestière
il ya quelques décennies des centaines
de bûcheron arrivés par train à plus
haut va pour se rendre dans les camps
forestiers
les premiers entretiens ont commencé ici
on a commencé à exploiter le beau dès
1856 en mauricie pour fourni en
angleterre les grands modes bateau les
grands pas une crainte qui sont
inexistants pratiquement à l'heure
actuelle le biologiste de conservation
pierre-olivier boudreau s'est et reste à
la foresterie depuis des années un
strict est en déclin les emplois ont
fondu des usines ont fermé
[Musique]
cette décroissance est manifeste à clova
la gare centenaire et patrimoniale 30
toujours au coeur de l'ancien village
mais il ne reste qu'une douzaine
d'habitants de dire qu'on investit
massivement au québec pour prendre peut
mettre cette industrie là quand même sur
le respirateur artificiel
c'est à eau des questions dans sa région
la façon dont le ministère des forêts
cher nos ressources est loin de faire
consensus
c'est des choses qu'on voit au sein de
ce mystérieux qui montre un but que
c'est difficile d'intégrer les autres
vacations de la forêt et si je peux
penser aux récréotourisme et aussi à la
protection de la biodiversité la
protection de la faune c'est certain
qu'on aimerait avoir peut-être de
pouvoir je vous dirais le travail de
silos du lendemain c'est centralisé à
québec nous ce qu'on aimerait voir c'est
qu'on essaie but rouleau ici ailleurs au
québec aussi les critiques fusent de
toutes parts
[Musique]
et n'a fait qu'enchaîner aussi que la
forêt est public s'est fait peur au
monde riche en sucre
c'est lui qui est parti en croisade pour
sauver nos forêts il y a deux décennies
a repris la plume avec son accord et
henri jacob cette fois pour dénoncer le
ministère l'heure actuelle ma soirée si
c'était une seule ayache mignola ben
c'est comme ça que c'est perçu par 1 go
dans les ministères par son bond girl
aux fonctionnaires qui dirigent tout
bien d'autres bien d'autres intérêts
la forêt il yad'autres à l'eau d'autres
vertus elle a d'autres d'autres beautés
à d'autres richesses mais on est leur
pire et aucun pouvoir pour on peut pas
forcer à ce que ses dimensions là
apparaissent aussi dans la pratique
selon l'artiste plus ça change plus
c'est pareil le ministère lui est
toujours resté dans son tunnel où est ce
qu'ils considèrent son son manteau comme
c'est d'accorder le plus de points
possibles aux compagnies qui sont
majoritairement les grosses compagnies
sont rendus américaine des sources au
sein du ministère des forêts nous
confirme comment ça se passe on est
toujours en train d'éteindre des feux
toutes les commandes core soit au bas de
l'échelle se concentre sur la façon
qu'on doit servir l'industrie
cette source comme d'autres dans ce
reportage a accepté de nous parler sous
le sceau de la confidentialité au sein
du ministère bien des fonctionnaires ont
à coeur l'avenir des forêts mais c'est
l'omerta difficile de remettre le
système en cause certains protestent à
leur façon en fait il ya plusieurs
ingénieurs qui refuse d'apposer leurs
signatures professionnels
sur les documents parce que le travail
est bâclé et on tourne les coins ronds
sega rocher ya tellement d'improvisation
même quand les entreprises ne prennent
pas les normes environnementales au
sérieux son travail consiste à leur
obtenir des dérogations pour que les
coupes forestières se poursuivent en
protégeant le mieux possible les
écosystèmes en fait on est là pour
l'industrie qui dit fais ce danois ça
change parce que c'est trop rigide ce
qui est sur papier qui viennent québec
c'est pour la réalité du terrain
cette fonctionnaire mais pas seul à
vivre ses frustrations
la grogne est tellement forte que
l'ordre des ingénieurs forestiers du
québec a demandé une enquête sur la
pratique de ses membres pour savoir ce
qui me tourner par an l'hymne à la haye
ce qu'il nous ce qui nous était
d'apporter des banques tu l avec
laquelle on a voulu savoir si c'était
généralisée ingérence politique comment
décousu lourdeurs administratives manque
d'imputabilité surcharge de travail
pression de l'industrie et décision qui
émane du bureau du sous-ministre sans
consultation des régions où se font les
coupes forestières les ingénieurs
forestiers en ont gros sur le coeur
c'est préoccupant quand on entend ce
définitivement le vermandois entracte de
ça il est le responsable de cette
gestion des forêts
il est le responsable de notre
patrimoine collectif
le ministère avait financé en partie
cette enquête auprès des ingénieurs
forestiers mais il a fait retirer son
nom du rapport en voyant les conclusions
le reboisement est un autre dossier
épineux que le ministère traîne comme un
boulet on peut bûcher bleuse parce que
on dit que les dames ou sylvicoles qu'on
effectue vont donner des meilleurs forêt
dans 30 40 1 tout service ceci complique
pas hypothétique
on n'est pas aujourd'hui de porter des
résultats de la circulation depuis 30 40
50 1
dans ses rapports en 2002 et en 2017 le
vérificateur général du québec a
critiqué le manque de suivi de
plantation d'arbres et parler de leur
succès mitigé notre source au ministère
confirme que le reboisement se fait pas
toujours dans les règles de l'art
l'ingénieur lui va décider planter un
nombre d'arbres par hectare mais le
gestionnaire pour des raisons
budgétaires va planter - dable sur une
plus grande superficie pour que ça
paraisse dit parce qu'au final c'est le
nombre d'hectares boisés qui tente le
gouvernement a investi plus de 3
milliards de dollars au cours des 15
dernières années en travaux sylvicoles
c'est ce que la forêt repousse bien
au québec avec les rues en sens faudrait
avoir une mesure des effets qui soit
solide ce qui est pas le cas à ce jour
québec ne sait toujours pas si l'argent
investi a donné les résultats escomptés
c'est peut-être à cause de ce genre de
situation que le ministère des forêts
arrive 18e sur 20 au palmarès du
gouvernement le tableau de bord qui
évalue la performance de ses propres
ministère il ya plusieurs gestionnaires
à québec et en région qui sont d'une
autre génération et qui gère ça comme
avant même si leurs connaissances sont
pas tout à fait à jour
ils veulent garder la main mise sur les
dix ça génère une guerre du pouvoir à
l'intérieur du ministère entre les
forestiers traditionnelle et la nouvelle
garde qui a davantage la fibre
écologique
l'agenda public du ministre des forêts
de la faune et des parcs et celui de son
sous-ministre obtenus grâce à la loi
d'accès à l'information démontrent qu'il
ya une disproportion des intérêts
économiques
notre secteur forêt site très important
pour les belles soeurs qui vient
bénéficiera grandement des occasions
générés par ce projet créateur comme le
premier ministre a dit de plus de 300
emplois de qualité
depuis son entrée en poste à la fin 2018
le ministre pierre dufour a rencontré
des représentants de l'industrie a au
moins une trentaine de reprises et des
élus des municipalités forestière plus
d'une dizaine de fois
hormis une tournée de consultation sur
le caribou forestier
aucune rencontre avec des groupes
environnementaux ou des organismes de
conservation ne figurent à son agenda
même chose pour son sous-ministre même
pas raconter les vous qu'ils pensent
qu'une arme plus de valeur de burqa
n'est qu'un homme couché c'est dans
l'adn ministère bref le ministère serait
au service de l'industrie malgré la loi
qui l'obligent à aménager durablement
les forêts malgré les bonnes intentions
du régime forestier qu'on demeure dans
un ministère qui est à vocation
économique qui est correct mais le corps
le contre-pouvoir qui devrait exister
avec l'environnement n'est pas là faut
plus qui se considèrent comme des
pourvoyeurs poupée qui considère qu'une
forêt c'est une cour en bois compagnie
c'est un réservoir de main comme c'est
de ce que ce soit une forme et pour
richard desjardins qui elle changera
tant qu'on ne prendra pas les grands
moyens jusque atteint car encore
vraiment une enquête sur la gestion du
non pas de la gestion forestière en
général comme hub et amène ses pantins
une enquête sur la gestion du ministère
lui même
au retour les consultations sur les
aires protégées qualifié par certains de
bidons personnellement j'ai aucunement
l'impression d'avoir du poids dans la
balance on dirait que c'est plus déjà
cannes et un amant
[Musique]
vous le savez les coupes forestières
suscite la colère un peu partout au
québec et depuis longtemps il y avait un
certain espoir avec le projet d'aires
protégées
sauf que l'écrasante majorité de ces
projets est rejetée la richesse
forestière du québec
vos keno delà de l'industrie les gens
profitent de la forêt pour vivre des
moments de détente ou d' aventure
chasser pêcher ou simplement profiter du
paysage
et ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
contester les coupes forestières sur le
terrain la colère monte en faire le
ministère la forêt appartient à tout le
monde dans un sens moi je suis vraiment
inquiet je trouve que la balance est
vraiment débat lancé en faveur des
forestiers le résultat est que des bouts
milieu comme s'approche des centres
urbains sont sous une menace d'être
dénaturée il s'appelle sébastien il est
le propriétaire de la pourvoirie
pavillon basile hier à saint zénon dans
lanaudière
depuis des années il se bat pour éviter
qu'une ferait centenaires soit rasé aux
autres ils voulaient couper tout ça ici
c'est tout ce qu'on voit là le ministère
des forêts a proposé aux compagnies
forestières d'abattre des arbres sur les
terres publiques loué à la pourvoirie il
y a eu des consultations sébastien s'y
est rendu pour s'opposer mais ça n'a
rien changé
personnellement j'ai aucunement
l'impression d'avoir du poids dans la
balance on dirait que c'est plus déjà
cas ni en amont
pour éviter que le paysage de sa
pourvoirie soit défiguré il a développé
un projet terre protégée il ya sept ans
il à débourser des milliers de dollars
en frais d'avocats pour négocier avec
l'industrie on est arrivé à une entente
ou des notaires lacombe aurait protégé
réservé à vocation forestière
le projet qui faisait l'unanimité dans
sa région a été recommandé au
gouvernement
la pourvoirie correspond en tout point
du territoire ciblé par une femme
environnement pourquoi une protection
qu'elle a des forêts très ancienne et
mature sébastien a donc été stupéfait
d'apprendre en décembre dernier qu'il ne
fait pas partie des nouvelles aires
protégées créé par québec mois sa
première fois de ma vie que j'assiste à
un consensus sur 15 intervenants de
milieux différents incluant les
forestiers pour qu'au final ça soit
balayée d'un revers de la main
selon nos sources c'est un bras de fer
entre le ministre de l'environnement et
le ministre des forêts qui a décidé du
sort des aires protégées
le premier voulait protéger la
biodiversité le second les coupes
forestières et les emplois c'est le
ministère des forêts qui a gagné les
autorités gouvernementales ont décidé
que ça toucherait pas aux volumes de
bois récoltables ou très peu et ce peu
importe les consensus locaux comme pour
la pourvoirie de sébastien selon ce
lanceur d'alert ce serait plutôt la
menace des pertes d'emplois dans les
régions forestières ou la cale de se
faire élire 4il dessus les députés du
gouvernement actuel sont pas beaucoup à
montréal sont plutôt dans les régions
ressources
donc un enjeu politique les lobbys
industriels sont extrêmement puissants
c'est pas facile non plus pour les
politiciens de tenir la barre devant ces
lobbys l'a83 proposition d'aires
protégées n'ont pas été retenus par le
gouvernement
québec a atteint sa cible pour préserver
17 % du territoire en 2020 mais il
s'agit surtout de son nous les forêts ne
sont pas exploitables par l'industrie
loin des centres urbains qu'on voit que
beaucoup de projets retenus dans la
partie nordique du territoire mais très
très peu dans la partie sud
ce fonctionnaire qui a travaillé plus
d'une décennie sur le dossier des aires
protégées au ministère de
l'environnement avec des collègues du
ministère des forêts se sent trahi il a
exigé l'anonymat par peur de
représailles
la question de l'environnement fait pas
le poids dans un gouvernement qui en
fait pas vraiment un tout aussi
important il ya de la place pour une
industrie forestière encore très bonne
très importante mais le lobby des
dernières années ça à faire en sorte
qu'on a pu le contrôle de nos forêts
publiques
et pourtant plusieurs des aires
protégées n'ont retenu à lui obtenu le
feu vert de fonctionnaires du ministère
des forêts whissell avait des impacts
sur les foires exploitables mais on
avait donné des avis favorables automne
dernier
si sur tous les districts sanitaires
les politiciens ont répondu à ses
inquiétudes ça a été une surprise pour
notre source
on peut pas ménager la chèvre et le chou
tout le temps à un moment donné il ya
les choix de société qu'il faut faire
puis on s'attendait à ce qu'il ya des
oeuvres protégées qui pense au prochain
à québec va se fixer une nouvelle cible
vert protégé à atteindre d'ici 2030
l'analyse des prochaines ont sélectionné
va donc se poursuivre mais des citoyens
parlent de deux poids deux mesures les
gens sont écoeurés on a participé durant
dix quinze vingt ans selon les critères
établis par le gouvernement pour
m'ouvrir dire en bout de ligne je
rentrai chez vous c'est le ministère qui
ordonne au greffier de coupe et intel
forêt avec eux c'est que les claques
signé c'est bon on va raser plusieurs
kilomètres carrés de forêt par contre
quand les citoyens veulent protéger un
territoire donné
on parle de minimum vingt deux des douze
travaux d'astérix comme on dit pour
qu'au final comme on vient de le faire
arriver à juste une non réponse
d'un autre côté l'alliance forêt boréale
qui représente les communautés
forestières du saguenay lac saint jean
du nord du québec et de la côte nord se
réjouit de voir que des aires protégées
annoncé ne touche pas au bois convoité
par les usines nous serons des impôts tv
oui mais faut pour saler d'impact sur
les parcelles comme président du
syndicat des travailleurs de la
papetière de dolbeau-mistassini pascal
cloutier s'est battu pour la réouverture
de son usine qui avait fermé en 2000
[Applaudissements]
250 familles avait alors perdu leur
gagne pain
aujourd'hui maire de la ville il s'est
promis de tout faire pour que ça
n'arrive plus jamais et il a maintenant
du poids au gouvernement avec sa
coalition dont on le voit quand on est
d'appel qui on écoute ses cheveux que
c'est ça fait pas tout un d'affaires de
certaines personnes
les interventions qu'on fait mais c'est
sonatro ses désarrois de ce
développement est loin ici de compliquer
le boom c'est ce n'est les environs bien
une bonne partie du
saguenay-lac-saint-jean ont cessé le
bois l'aluminium dans ses récentes
annonces québec n'a retenu qu'une aire
protégée sur les 25 projets présentés
dans sa région le territoire marécageux
traversée par une ligne haute tension et
voisin d'un ancien dépotoir avaient été
proposés par l'industrie
au saguenay-lac-saint-jean par contre
une des régions que le plus beau ratio
d'aires protégées au québec
est-ce que c'est grâce à votre travail
ben c'est grave
oui il ya une partie nous ça fait
longtemps qu'on fait des réparations
puis je pense vraiment que ça fait une
différence
il existait pourtant des secteurs au
potentiel récréotouristique
internationale comme le corridor de la
rivière péribonka qui est bordé
d'écosystèmes forestiers rare mais voilà
que le ministère des forêts ils
planifient des coupes forestières la
charge et en général d'accord là
plusieurs bus et là ils s'en foutent
chabot la vallée aux compagnies chez soi
quand il est question de cours
forestière aussi que le processus de
concertation et de consultation mis en
place dans les régions et qu'elle est
fier de bidons même par des
fonctionnaires on consulte pas les gens
ont les efforts des jeunes sont
désillusionnés du ministère quand on
fait des recommandations s'est bloquée
par les gestionnaires d'aix arles n'est
pas que sur l'ego la principe dans le
fond c'est ne pas accorder les
utilisateurs du fond on a beau dire on a
peut expliquer mais des fois et là ça
pose problème
il va falloir qu'on nous écoute parce
que nous autres on en connaissant le
territoire le chef d'obedjiwan qualifie
d' exponentielle les coupes forestières
sur le territoire attikameks mais il dit
que le ministère n'est pas réceptif à
ses préoccupations
le conseil de bande n'est pourtant par
contre l'industrie
il est copropriétaire d'une série qui
contribuent à l'économie de la
communauté savoir vu depuis sa coupe au
fond aux autres on est très lié à la
terre vraiment avoir le territoire du
forez station personnes ça nous fait
quelque chose
à saint zénon sébastien bonjour lui
touche du bois en espérant que la nature
se venge qu'il vend aux clients de sa
pourvoirie ne passera pas sous les
abatteuses
après la pause est ce que l'industrie
paye vraiment le juste prix pour ce qu'
elle récolte
il ya toujours un écart dans presque
tous les mesurages en faveur de la
compagnie dans tout ce qu'on vous a
présenté une grande préoccupation pour
la conservation de la forêt la
protection de l'environnement
mais parlons de notre portefeuille un
instant est ce que le gouvernement
permet à certaines compagnies
forestières de s'en mettre plein les
poches
[Musique]
lydia petit coin aime la nature les
arbres sont au centre de sa vie elle a
vu le jour à wemotaci l'un des
territoires autochtones de la haute
mauricie et au montage schiste qui a
vécu de feu feu de forêt on voit des
cicatrices porto s'est en outre
s'entourer c'est catherine dufour
c'est un peu comme ça que je vois aussi
que vous êtes vraiment persévérons
résistants elle est une des rares
attikameks avoir étudié en protection du
territoire faunique et en aménagement
forestier lydien fait le pont entre deux
cultures entre deux langues
les robes à sucre et les natures et
le boulot à papier ont dit oui gosse a
de quoi elle incarne l'avenir de
l'industrie en voulant à la fois
protéger la forêt comme l'ont fait ses
ancêtres et l'exploiter pour en vivre et
stimuler l'économie de sa communauté
c'est chez commonwealth plywood à la
tuque qu'elle vient de décrocher son
premier emploi comme classificatrice de
billes ici lydia inspectent chaque arbre
coupé pour en tirer le maximum de profit
d'un beau diable pour allait envoyer au
cinoche donc cette arme leur faveur à
venir des planches un plancher
finalement oui oui exact exactement les
bio deviennent des planchers de bois
franc du contreplaqué de la pâte à
papier ou du bois de chauffage
c'est moi de cacher qu'on du produit
pas de bouaké gospel par la compagnie
veut le portrait exact du contenu de sa
cour à bois
mieux elle le fait plus et les rentables
québécois aussi veulent en avoir pour
leur argent avec les arbres coupés par
l'industrie sur les terres publiques
mais le gouvernement qui fournit le voit
aux compagnies les ses clients mesurer
eux mêmes les volumes qu'ils achètent
c'est absolument pas normal que ce soit
le client qui dit aux fournisseurs
combien ce que bree de bois si le client
lui même qui décide du montant payé au
fournisseur qui le gouvernement pour
s'assurer de la quantité et de la
qualité du bois qui entrent dans les
usines
le système de mesurage que le ministère
des forêts relègue à l'industrie a deux
fonctions établir ce que les compagnies
doivent payer et connaître la capacité
de production de nos forêts
[Musique]
le mesurage c'est lui qui calcule tout
juste à partir de l'ocs sont basés tous
les chiffres au niveau de la
planification forestière
que ce soit les consommations du zen que
ce soit les paient pour les
entrepreneurs
que ce soit les redevances au
gouvernement
[Musique]
ce mesureur de l'industrie qui a oeuvré
dans différentes régions constate qu'au
fil des ans les québécois ont perdu des
millions de dollars avec le système
pernicieux les mesureurs subissent la
pression des employeurs pour faire le
plus grand gain de bois possible on doit
préserver son identité pour qu'il garde
de son emploi il ya toujours un écart
dans presque tous les mesurages en
faveur de la compagnie les et cork vous
avez vu les plus grands c'était de
l'ordre de quoi ça pouvait aller
facilement de l'ordre de 20 à 25 pour ça
dans les pires place les mesureurs vont
toujours avantagé la main qui les
nourrit ce qui l'accompagné
il connaît tous les trucs toutes les
failles du système
mauvaise échantillonnage balances
défectueuses soit dubois manipuler plus
les années passent plus le mesurage
fossé donné et il n'y a pas que québec
qui perd de l'argent
la paix des entrepreneurs qui coupent le
bois aussi repose sur des volumes biaisé
il ya vraiment personne au québec qui
sait combien qu'on bouche de bois c'est
des milliers de kilomètres carrés des
bretons le bûcher que personne n'a été
payée peau ni l'entrepreneur ni le
gouvernement en 2004 le rapport coulombe
remettait en cause la fiabilité du
système de mesure ajoute même
l'industrie il appelait à une
augmentation de la quantité et de la
rigueur des contrôles de l'état
mais 17 ans plus tard la situation s'est
détériorée selon nos sources du
compagnies sont rendus des
professionnels pour s'avantager un même
le mesurage plus le gouvernement n'en
sort la façon dont je le vois de moins
en moins d'effectifs pour faire le
contrôle
candy viennent seuls terrains pour les
mesures ça devient souvent prévisibles
la visite du vérificateur
les vérificateurs c'est celui qui
s'assure que les québécois reçoivent 100
% de leur dû joanes laframboise était
responsable des vérifications à mauricie
elle vient de prendre sa retraite du
ministère des forêts après 40 ans de
service
le système ne fonctionne plus la façon
le cul qui était fait ça ne fonctionne
plus présentes mais qu'est ce qu'on a à
peine s'est il faut donner servi sa
cliente et à l'industrie notre clientèle
c'est l'industrie je n'avais plus le
temps de faire ma job en tant que tel
qui était de vérifier pour être ce que
le bourg et tu as bien déclare réunion
ces dernières années elle a vu fondre le
nombre de vérificateurs au ministère
québec s'en remet à la bonne foi des
mesureurs embauché par les usines et à
un système informatisé
c'est comme tuer de donner un cheikh
arabe les nounous prescrit en notre sein
d'unistar dit on un système un système
qui contrôle le système de contrôle pas
tout l'opérateur historique du hockey it
make it embarqués ils tendent à créer sa
propre piste est à d'epinay pour laisser
version il repart c'est de la balle à
oslo pour son outil sous les arbres
n'ont pas tous la même valeur certains
coûtent 50 cents le mètre cube alors que
d'autres coûte 50 dollars
comme il ya moins de vérification sur le
terrain le gouvernement peut donc se
faire passer littéralement enfin sapin
tu vas parler avec des mesurettes soit
parlé avec d'autres vérificateur tout le
monde d écoute ça pour péter herrmann et
sa prod a lieu depuis quelques années
nos sources assiste à un relâchement des
normes de mesurage en faveur de
l'industrie la population en général
satan du gouvernement qui défende ses
intérêts puis nous sur le terrain c'est
pas vraiment ce qu'on constate en fait
sur le terrain
les vérificateurs du gouvernement
n'aurait plus de marge de manoeuvre pour
sanctionner les fautifs 50 ou du bétail
se montreront aussi la racaille qu'au
bout de la ligne sera pas plus loin
c'est moi je vais pas le cas langues
l'ont bien montré confiant à quatre dans
des compagnies cui ont lu des
infractions il y en a de moins en moins
parce que c'est un kata et ne put de
pétanque sont des enquêteurs c'est johan
laframboise a alerté ses supérieurs sur
les brèches du système et la baisse de
qualité du bois déclarée mais il aurait
fermé les yeux
elle croit que changements s'imposent
les infrastructures devraient être gérés
par le ministère aux sorties de forêt un
coup que tu sais qu est-ce que sortie de
deux fois aurait apprécié a battu le
vert puis garde de ne plus de problèmes
le mesureur de l'industrie a décidé de
briser le silence parce qu'ils
s'inquiètent pour l'avenir des forêts
qu'il va léguer à ses petits enfants
j'ai pas qu'on se réveille un beau matin
puis qu'on leur laisse à eux une terre
brûlée
il a lui aussi un conseil pour le
gouvernement il devrait faire le
mesurage lui même puis même je dirais
même plus le mesurage devrait être fait
par un organisme indépendant
ça devrait dire si tu veux la juste
mesure c'est la seule façon de faire
l'an dernier le bois coupé sur les
terres publiques a rapporté la majeure
partie des revenus du ministère qui
était de 337 millions tandis que ses
dépenses élevées à 873 millions
il est donc dans le rouge pour plus d'un
demi milliard et sa révolte entre autres
richard desjardins ce qu'on leur paye
les entreprises fort et c'est assez
énorme de illich main puis chez eux
c'est une zone qui irait pas à la forêt
une fois que georges authentique le bois
si le débat sur la forêt québécoise
oppose économie et environnement la
volonté de régionaliser les décisions
unit les deux camps
tant qu'on descend trévise euros pour le
pouvoir décisionnel du ministère des
forêts en région savoie dit c'est comme
ça c'est parce qu'au niveau du
gouvernement
c'est le mur à mur qui existe et le clic
vous entendez d'un peu tout le monde
nistos mur à mur l'eau dans les régions
pour certains il faut carrément créer
des organismes régionaux uni l'industrie
ni le ministère ne serons maître
d'oeuvre alors on n'a pas cet espace là
de trouver des solutions de compromis au
niveau local au niveau régional ce
devrait être une commission une
commission ou un groupe indépendant
composé de au minimum deux biologistes
et d'ingénieurs fruges avec l'allemand
d'ordre décrire exactement qu'est ce
qu'on peut justement exploité d'une
forêt c'est quoi le niveau
d'exploitation est adaptée à chaque
territoire
nous avons fait une demande d'entrevue
au ministre des forêts de la faune et
des parcs pierre dufour son cabinet nous
a plutôt référer à ses fonctionnaires et
à ses sous ministre associé une offre
que nous avons décliné parce qu'ils
n'ont pas la responsabilité politique du
dossier
[Musique]
l'idée un petit coup et qui représente
la réconciliation des différentes
visions de la forêt à vous avec un
trémolo dans la voix qu'elle aspire un
jour à devenir chef de sa communauté
pour aider à changer les choses
plus grave c'est vraiment pour des cons
se développe de façon respectueuse
c'est sûr je me sers que je vois ça en
mouvement
[Musique]
oh
j'espère que vous avez apprécié de
reportages de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
la semaine prochaine exceptionnellement
je sais de l'antenne à ma collègue
céline galipeau qui vous a préparé une
émission spéciale pour souligner le
premier anniversaire de la pandémie
donc je vous dis à ton de semaine pour
une autre enquête
[Musique]